and when you're done coffee about that
later yeah but there's not going to be
kind of just curious like I think your
chain please but you don't get tired you
guys a lot of times you defended you in
the garden yes if you just broke my
office I want to talk to you about Alien
and Sedition Act because you know you
were waiting to make a decision about
locking up dissident we'll talk about
that in a fortnight yes of it in a
fortnight you'll be in Philadelphia
there won't be time all right
so week Adele's lovely car the real-time
physiatrist
the previous shop in here do the frames
in kindly remove yourself stop you just
broke my ribs and spectacles sort I saw
about the drug war of yours because I
know you were waiting to make your
decision about criminalizing nonviolent
drug use don't talk to about that later
god damnit right okay okay but there's
not going to be time I'm just second
part are you guys cooking Nixon erotic
who are you with those two bastards at
the post job yes I'm not you just broke
my glasses I'm shuckers mr. president I
want to ask you about the Indian Removal
Act you seem to be refusing to do your
constitutional duty to execute the
decisions of court stuff hold a treaty I
hate Indians okay thank you no problem
you look Cherokee for the Roosevelt
about the Japanese internment Oh sick
I'm tired of you newsmen sweet remember
you get the hell out of here you with
the Brooklyn daily eagle you've broken
my monocle
first fellow did the same goddamn thing
you just throw me mr. president you're
standing that's right you're standing up
it's an act all the rules just like the
Paul haar the bombing now you know too
much oh [ __ ] my Gil SummerSlam one
pastor is gonna round you and under that
and yes the mild what the cat is go
ahead
[Music]